three states out west have reached an
historic water agreement to keep the
Colorado River from going dry the
Colorado provides water for 40 million
people in seven states plus parts of
northern Mexico the proposed big deal
calls for big cuts Ben Tracy looks at
how much water the state's plan to give
up
it's a Lifeline for a river in critical
condition California Arizona and Nevada
have agreed on a proposal to conserve
nearly a trillion gallons of Colorado
River water much of that will come from
the federal government spending 1.2
billion dollars to pay Farmers cities
and Native American tribes to use less
water it shows Sacrifice by all three
states John inspinger runs the Southern
Nevada Water Authority and was part of
the negotiations so with this deal how
much water does Nevada have to give up
we'll be contributing a total of 285 000
acre feet between now and the end of
2026. that's more water than Las Vegas
uses in an entire year the water the
states can serve will be left in Lake
Mead the nation's largest Reservoir is
just about 30 percent full we visited
there in 2021 the white bathtub ring a
sign of Decades of drought and overuse
by Western States since 2000 Lake Mead
has dropped 130 feet that's hard to
imagine but picture a 13-story building
on top of my head way up there
that's where the water used to be since
then it's dropped even further a wet
winter out west is expected to boost
reservoirs in the river but long term
the federal government is worried they
could drop so low that water would no
longer flow through massive dams choking
off the water supply that's a huge
amount of water that is not flowing to
Farms is not going to cities Michael
Cohen of the Pacific Institute says
climate change means even more painful
Cuts will be needed so that's the future
it's a hotter drier climate which means
less water is available for CBS mornings
I'm Ben Tracy in Los Angeles